president honorable members say good
morning plastic pellet spills um give
phras uh like the recent event on the
Spanish Coast or uh the French Coast
last year give phrase to a wave of
public concern and such accidents are
occasional but they create sudden and
significant negative impact on some
regions other regions have been
struggling with the endemic pollution by
plastic pets due to poor handling at
every stage of the supply chain and such
pollution may not have be always as
visible as in major accidents but has
nth less harmful impacts on soils and
Waters on lives and livelihoods so the
need for Action is clear and that's why
in October last year the commission put
forward a proposal for a regulation on
preventing plastic pellet losses the
primary focus is on prevention because
once pellets enter the environment
they're difficult and costly to capture
and I would like to thank the parliament
for giving uh priority to the work of
this proposal in such a busy period of
Time coming back to the case at hand let
me begin with the tools that we already
have at the EU level to assist EU system
hosted in the European Maritime safety
agency allows the sharing of information
between countries on containers lost at
sea it was duly activated in this case
other forms of EU support are available
through the emergency response
coordination Center EU civil protection
mechanism for example and the EU
solidarity fund support might be also
available from funds such as the
European Maritime fisheries and
aquaculture fund and cohesion funds so
the reasons for the fall remain to be
investigated at as well as the
responsibilities in the meantime cleanup
is ongoing but these operations are
costly in terms of time and equipment
and they are also very challenging
especially at the sea and that's why
accidental and operational losses should
be best avoided in the first place and
when losses occur the polluter Pace
principle must apply so the commission
proposal on plastic pellet losses
requires economic operators to act in
the following order firstly they have to
take action to prevent any spills then
comes the contamin uh containment
obligation to ensure that spilled
pellets do not leak to the environment
and thirdly if pellets pollute the
environment cleanup must be ensured so
the proposal covers operators that
produce store or convert plastic pellets
into products and EU and non-eu carriers
transporting pellets by Road Rail and
inland waterways in the union given the
international nature of Maritime
transport this sector was not included
in the proposal so the commission is
however actively working at the
international Maritime organization to
tackle highly complex matter the IMO is
examining the issue of plastic pellets
transportation in containers intensively
notably on three aspects so firstly good
quality packaging to withstand the
shocks and handling normally encountered
during transport second transport
information to clearly identify those
fried containers containing plastic
pellets and thirdly safe storage to
minimize the hazards to the marine
environment specifically Freight fried
containers with plastic pellets should
be stoed under deck whenever possible or
in board in sheltered areas of exposed
decks so we are determined with the
support of the member states to speed up
this work with the international martime
organization and help take decisions
this would avoid ending up with a
patchwork of different different
Regional and National rules and in
particular given that many containers
are loaded onto ships in ports outside
the you so it's important that these
rules are agreed and adopted worldwide
to be effective at the same time we're
ready to consider the inclusion of
further Provisions in EU law on the
basis of the developments at the
international Maritime organization so
this could include a ban on the carriage
of pellets in bulk and also tighter
rules on the quality of package in and
the transport of pellets in the main
body of ships in this way we would
already reduce the risk of pellets
washing up on our beaches protecting
Coastal and marine ecosystems is in the
interest of all eu's blue economy
sectors including Fisheries aquaculture
and Coastal tourism are directly
affected by the plastic pellets
pollution so we need firm action by all
parties involved as sea waterers are
transboundary and this will require
close cooperation among member states
despite our efforts the sea remains
unpredictable and at times a dangerous
place to operate so adverse weather
conditions may unavoidably lead to
catastrophic events it is then that
remediation Solutions are necessary so
commission will pursue the evaluation of
marine strategy framework directive
which already contain Provisions to
protect the marine environment against
harm caused by litter the environmental
liability directive which offers limited
protection in this regard will will also
be subject to evaluation commission will
continue to contribute to the research
guidance promotion and support of best
handling practice with a view and
reducing uh any possible effects caused
by plastic pellets losses reducing
microplastic pollution is also an
objective of the EU Mission restore our
ocean and Waters which is developing and
demonstrating innovative solutions to
prevent eliminate and monitor
microplastics in our ocean and Waters
finally I'd like to point at the new
international instrument on plastic
pollution that is currently being
negotiated let me stress the importance
of including a legally binding
Provisions to prevent release of
plastics into the environment through
the life cycle I'm confident that
together we'll find the best way to deal
with the current crisis and pave the way
to preventing such crisis in the future
this enes the rapid adoption of The
Proposal on plastic pellets and I'm sure
that we will uh we are all United in our
determination to do all we can to avert
such ecological disasters thank
you thank you very much let us take the
speaker speaking on behalf of the
political groups Mrs cloon on behalf of
the EP thank you president and
commissioner and as we speak today
hundreds of workers and volunteers are
working day and night to clean up those
millions of plastic pellets that have
washed up on their Shores in Galia
they're doing so because they want to
protect their environment their fishing
their shellfish industry and their
livelihoods in the tourism sector and
they're asking questions how did this
happen could it have been prevented
could the extent of the damage that
we're seeing today have been reduced and
why was there such a delay before they
saw action and support from their
government what happened from the 8th of
December last to the 3rd of January why
did it take so long for their Regional
government to be informed so that they
could take action and they want to know
what's to be done at European level to
prevent to minimize and better
coordinate a response to such a serious
event in the future it has to be noted
that the company responsible for the
transport of these pellets did act and
inform as soon as they could they will
investigate how it happened and they
will contribute to the cleanup and I'm
glad to see the Spanish prose public
prosecutor has started an
investigation we must provide answers
but also we must give direction as to
how such a scenario can be avoided or
reduced in the future this spillage has
brought into Focus the regulation on
preventing microplastic pollution
currently that's been considered here in
this Parliament a regulation that aims
to see measures applied across the
Plastic industry chain to reduce pedet
loss by up to 70% and I want to see the
adoption of this report a practical
regulation that will be effective we
must act to prevent such spillages we
must commit to containing spillages to
reducing their impact in the environment
and we must have a coordinated cleanup
response to help and support those
vulnerable communities who suffer and
bear the brunt of these environmental
spills thank you very much on behalf of
the Socialists and Democrats Mr Gonzalez
casares
graas thank you president thank you
commissioner we're faced with a double
tide in galsia now a tide of plastic and
a tide of incompetence and lies from the
regional government of the PP its
pathetic mismanagement has left citizens
to own devices to do the clearup for
weeks now we've seen pollution caused by
microplastics a key priority for the
commission and the Socialists we're
taking this initiative forward pellets
are not beautiful which the government
of my my regional government is saying
they're danger to the environment and
potentially a danger to human health so
as the commissioner and the government
of Spain have said we need to combat
this plastic pollution needs to be
tackled we're seeing it now in galsia we
need strengthened EU legislation rather
than trying to brush things under the
carpet which is what the pp is trying to
do and also I would say to the pp
sometimes you're on the side of
pollution saying oh nothing to see here
uh we don't need more ambitious European
legislation but then the tide turns and
uh
you recognize that the problems which
have occurred due to
pollution in and uh Galia itself we
seeing the consequences of this
uh I see mon laughing there but it's
been uh terrible mismanagement in Galia
Europe thank you very much on behalf of
renew Europe Mrs
Shambo thank you very much president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen in
this hemicycle all the plastic
objects were uh pellets before because
that's how you start making plastic for
years our Co coasts have been affected
by oil spills but now we have these
white Tides but of course this is also
very harmful because the pellets uh get
mixed up with sand and they also come
from oil uh I'm thinking of our Spanish
colleagues I'm thinking of what's
happening and I think it is absolutely
necessary to have effective prevention
measures measures now there are
solutions on the table they've been
there for a long time but they're not
implemented and they're not so difficult
to implement uh we have uh leaks and
Spills throughout the whole process um
uh when these plastic pets are
manufactured but how can we have them
actually uh falling into the sea we have
to push the IMO to look at container
traceability and when working on plastic
pellets I would also push you to work on
the plastic pellet traceability so
traceability of the pellets themselves
in order to establish responsibility
thank
you thank you very much on behalf of the
greens Mrs scar Keller dear colleagues
unfortunately the catastrophe that we
see in gala happening is just a tip of
an enormous Iceberg the pollution of our
sea with over a billion plastic pallets
is a huge disaster for the envir
environment for marine animals and for
the local communities but this disaster
is not even 1% of the plastic pallets
lost every single year we need to stop
this ongoing catastrophe no one is
gaining anything from unused plastic
pallets flakes or powders getting lost
it's high time to give clear
requirements to producers handlers and
carriers of plastic raw materials to
make sure that plastic pallet losses are
prevented and if they happen report it
and there is a liability for those
carriers and handlers the commissioner
has put forward a proposal that I very
much welcome and I'm sure the parliament
will make sure that this legislation
will become even stronger and more
waterproof let us let us not wait until
more disasters are happening in Galicia
or elsewhere let's put an end to this
wasteful handling of our very limited
resources let's just not leave a plastic
trace on our planet thank thank
you thank you very much on behalf of the
ECR Mr
buba thank you president the beaches of
Galicia have been inundated with pellets
and do you only care about elections
when there was an environmental disaster
although beaches are in the public
domain uh they playing a political card
and then the pp playing the
anti-nationalist card the best thing to
do would be get out of it and spare us
this pathetic spectacle because you
don't give a hoot for the uh cleanliness
of beaches we need to start local with
beaches with uh forests with uh Rivers
we need a conservative patriotic policy
which will protect our environment we're
not just talking about pollution on
beaches we're talking about survival of
the Fisheries sector and the Socialists
and others for 4 40 years now have been
systematically implementing foreign
agendas processing outsourced Fisheries
restrictions restricted economic areas
extended abusive EU overreach turning
galicians into people who dependent on
others 25% of uh European uh ports with
more than 21% drop in catches 20,000
jobs lost since 2004 15% of processing
businesses going under aging population
and an aging fishing fleet meanwhile
outside the EU we see 97% growth in 10
years thanks to your friends in China
and Morocco that's the true uh
disaster you've created this flourishing
sector but outside the EU and until we
care about uh EU Fisheries we won't be
able to deal with this less pellets more
vessels thank you very much on behalf of
identity and democracy Mrs
B thank you very much president
commissioner last month Europe witnessed
a new Maritime catastrophe there were
millions of plastic pellets that were
thrown into the Atlantic ocean near the
Spanish Coast this is not a new
phenomenon because every year there 230
million tons of U these sort of
this sort of waste that ends up in the
seas and two-thirds of this pollution
comes from Europe on its own so the
European Union does have a weighty
responsibility to deal with these
disasters but this is basically down to
their unbridled economic policies and
the left wi who is exploiting this sort
of situation just for electoral aims so
looking at what's going on between China
and the us or what's going on in the Red
Sea once again we're paying a very high
price of our dependence on the rest of
the world we need to act to
reindustrialize Europe not just for the
European citizens and for their
purchasing power but also for the
environment and for
sovereignty the M the same mistakes are
provoking the same errors so uh time on
time let's stop
this on behalf of the left group Mrs
vioa Ruiz thank you very much
president um more than a month after the
plastic pellets will uh spin that has
overwhelmed Galan and other coasts the
regional government of the pp is denying
this the same that denied climate change
and that said uh that even when the
prestige oil spill took place it wasn't
that serious not only did they say that
the pellets uh aren't toxic but that you
can even eat them that is the level
responsibility and uh lack of Shame so
we need European legislation ambitious
legislation that will put an end to
business impunity that are not assuming
responsibility and liability and this is
stopping the authorities from acting
immediately of course we have to protect
the environment and our Fisheries sector
the spill on the 8th of December was a
disaster but what has happened since
then is pure negligence never
again thank you very much we've come to
the end of the list of speakers speaking
on behalf of the political groups now
Mrs dansy you president commissioner
colleagues plastic pellets are one of
the major sources of micr plastic
pollution in the air water and soil they
can spread they can spread through our
bodies and animals bodies the
commission's ambitious aim of reducing
plastic released R
70% is a breath of life for our marine
and uh land ecosystems so to suffer uing
from pollution we need better practices
mandatory certification harmonized
methodology for prevention and
inspection of microplastic pollutions
those are the kind of SP smart Solutions
which we need so that uh stakeholders in
the sector can see that there are very
clear rules and instruments that can be
used purely in the interest of
Health we only have one uh
chance for health and this kind of
toxicity can easily lead to death so we
need to strive for the Europe we want to
see thank you very much Mrs
monserat thank you very much president
to you from the
left are you really so nervous uh that
you're going to lose at the polls again
on the Spanish Coast it's not just the
gisan coast we're getting pellets from a
container they're washing up on the
shores we could be talking about the 350
people that are working on 55 beaches
and helicopters and what the uh Galan
Regional government is doing but you're
not interested because what the left
wants to do is to gain uh something from
this crisis something they couldn't get
uh in other ways
now I would like to say that you uh gave
into pimont fugitive from justice but
yet you're slow to deal with this crisis
that affects everyone Galia is acting
you act as well because you have powers
here to ask you to show responsibilities
too much but at least stop being
opportunistic and stop lying thank
you thank you very much Mr Abu
Ker
26 tons of micro plastic pellets across
the coast of galsia and dous tragic
images of millions of pellets polluting
our environment I would like to express
my support and gratitude to our Galician
brothers and sisters who are spending
day after day clearing up their beaches
I presented
report on prevention of microp plastic
pollution the aim was to take the
commission proposal forward in relation
to three key uh aspects when pellets are
lost in the environment they're
extremely difficult to recover for that
reason all of our efforts should go into
effective prevention measures to reduce
or even eliminate losses of such pellets
into the environment This Disaster has
also made it clear that we need to
extend legislation to cover maritime
transport too as the commissioner was
saying we need to bring more pressure to
bear in the international Maritime
organization to ensure that we have
effective measures governing European
territory deterrent measures there are
different operators along the value
chain that need to be effectively
involved in strengthening sanction
measures but I also want to be clear
that no European citizen no Galician
citizen should see a accountability for
those responsible for protecting our
ecosystems finally a plea let us not
uh say okay this happened on one Beach
that's happened let then people take
electoral advantage of this in political
debates we need to look at the solution
for the people of galsia uh we don't
want another traumatic event like the
one of 21 uh years ago let us take the
right path of history now thank you very
much Mr
tval Mr Speaker dearest
commissioner I have with me three
different reports here and they are all
telling the same sad
story containers lost at sea is a huge
problem the catastrophe outside or off
the coast of part Portugal and Spain
actually had there was six con
containers what we see in the reports it
goes for the US vessel l it goes for the
ever Smart is that the containers are
usually stucked in a criminal
way in the future with more storms
you're going to have more problems more
catastrophes if we don't get the vessels
in order the equipment is bad the
vessels are are old and they are stucked
in a way Accord which is not going
according to the rules so what you have
on the top of a stack is a too heavy
container and when the ship starts
rolling 20% to the left and to starboard
and and and and Port then you have it
there so we have to get the rules to
work and if we don't get them the
catastrophes catastrophes will be there
thank
[Applause]
you thank you very much Mrs
Miranda
following the environmental disaster
affecting my country of galsia I launch
a call for actor it's not only a problem
for Galia it's for the whole of Europe
we saw through December that the pellets
were spreading but it was a month later
in January
that the uh official communication took
place so the government of galsia and
the people of Gia felt completely
abandoned and left to their own devices
Maria Lago I would like to thank who's
here here and uh the mayor of Rea and
all of those who've engaged in the clear
up Activity thank you to those members
from five groups for signing the letter
which we will send to you uh Commission
galsia is not alone and the
anti-pollution uh level two alert only
came in late too if you listen to people
from the pp you hear these slogans
coming from uh Gala about improvisation
negligence lack of
transparency the pp government is
calling them little plastic balls but
we're talking about thousands of bags of
pellets that are
are
spreading such levels of incompetence
look at the unique biodiversity and
Marine ecosystem of galsia the huge
impact on the marine environment this
has a KnockOn effect on fishes and on
people's way of life the pp government
has been harming this way of life for uh
many years now and it goes beyond that
to the whole fishery sector so no uh
distraction tactics please there'll be a
demonstration in Santiago on Sunday with
different uh collectives but the
mismanagement is nothing new we went
there with the prestige to nothing has
been learned since then and a marketing
company linked to the pp has been
involved in the clear up of uh pellets
with a a uh coat from uh the protective
jacket with from the shunter saying oh
well where this that'll be better it's
all about PR we're talking about
dangerous materials with significant
accidents with consequences for the
environment and the new microplastics
loss regulation needs to cover
this Galicia deserves better it deserves
a responsible
government you have a blue card from Mr
guau do you accept it yes
democ 30 seconds for
you
who
Miranda Miss Miranda solidarity with
Galia solidarity with the people of
galaa in the light of these events
picking up on what you said given that
the M Municipal chamber president is
here what support was there from the
government of Galicia the Portuguese
media were saying that there had been uh
prefect level and NGO
level Fishers level activity uh without
much support from the regional
government is that
true thank you for that question the pp
government in Galicia as you said took
at least a month to get uh State uh
assistance we are still waiting in
galsia there are 169 workers hired by
the government of uh Galia over
1,500 K kilometers don't interrupt me uh
they are rejecting the offers from the
government of the state so I'd like to
thank those uh representatives and the
100 or more people I don't have this in
in Spanish I don't have this in uh
writing you had a response in than you
much
Mrs Miranda thank you very much you have
more than enough time to answer Mr ter
you have the
floor good morning
everyone just to make it all clear on
the 18th of February there are elections
in Galicia it's a beautiful region of
Spain with beautiful beautiful Coastline
but we've got plastic pallets washing up
but taragona in Catalonia have also
grappled with the same problem but yet
we didn't have such a debate don't
worry the title misses the point uh
there isn't an ecological disaster it's
the wrong title of the debate there is a
problem to solve but it's just one more
problem to solve but the problem is that
the Spanish government the Spanish
government uh has uh basically carried
out
so they like anything that allows them
to talk about other issues anything but
the
amnesty and they were told that there is
a coup uh and that they are destroying
the Spanish Judiciary so they'd rather
look for little plastic ballls or
pellets because it's easier to do that
pellets that are apparently a disaster
so and then there's the Galician
government too I think they should all
look at protecting the gisan coast more
and fighting against agenda 2030 which
is responsible for what is happening
there the next speaker is Mrs Marisa
Matias thank you president colleagues we
don't often see such a clear
demonstration of complete indifference
to people and people's suffering as
we've just heard I'd like to start by
thanking Miss mirand for uh putting a
finger on the nub of this crucial issue
it's an environmental disaster once
again for the people of galsia 26 tons
of plastic pellets ending up in the sea
just like with the prestige 20 years ago
it was incompetence from the pp gysan
authorities totally unacceptable our
marine ecosystems being polluted by
plastic pellets is something which
cannot be faced with impunity in Galia
or anywhere else in the world we see uh
a growing problem and in Spring we'll be
talking not only about galissa but
Portugal and France their coastlines too
so we need ambitious proposals to avoid
microplastic pollution to prevent it so
that this uh phenomenon can cease to
exist so we see uh uh environmental
disaster denialism here played out in
real time by some Spanish representative
thank you very much Mr
sinic thank you very much plastic
pallets and uh their influence on the
environment is significant and any
ecological disaster is a loss for life
on Earth but uh most of the waste uh in
the sea comes from Land not the sea so
uh waste management is crucial in every
country in the EU with Recycling and
waste management maybe it is better for
some countries to join their efforts
together for Waste Management efforts uh
let us not um deceive ourselves uh there
is a very little level of uh Waste
Management in Europe most uh waste is
not now exported to China but to tavan
and other countries in the city of
Zagreb we had disaster at the waste
management site uh also in oek and in
Vin so all the centers for Waste
Management are a disaster for the cities
and the local man local U uh governments
and the local government in Zagreb is
not able to handle this situation and uh
also we have seen uh who is in charge of
the environment protection fund uh and
uh uh this is a criminal activity croats
need to uh find political courage to
stop this and stop the environment thank
you very much Mrs Pereira is
next an accident that should never
happen happened over 1,000 bags of
microplastic pellets now along the coast
of the the north of Spain galissa since
the beginning of the year the government
of Portugal the regional government of
galissa the national government of Spain
could not have avoided this because of
the nature of the ACT accident but when
people have powers when people have
responsibilities it is incumbent upon
them to respond
properly we saw uh prompt And Timely
commun communication from the government
of Portugal but Pedro Sanchez was
playing politics with this and we saw
the hypocrisy of the bsoe the Spanish
Socialist Party passing the buck
incompetence and M misleading
distortions trying to point the finger
of blame at the regional government of
galsia whereas in fact it was the uh
Regional government of galsia that was
the only party really concerned about
minimizing the consequences of uh the uh
incident Sanchez and his government if
they had a scrap of political Dignity
should be asking for forgiveness
particularly from the people of galsia
because of the awful environmental
impact of their policies I also think
it's a bit odd that when we ask for a
debate on the rule of law in Spain we
accused accused of being too National in
our focus and now suddenly we're accused
of being too Regional well Chapo to the
left the next speaker is Mr
Bal president commissioner
colleagues 160 tons of plastic
pellets and 12 million tons of plastic
of various
types are spilled bu into our seas and
oceans every year it is very well known
that uh plastic plastic waste has
negative influence at for fish and
humans who are at risk of consuming it
directly or indirectly the ecological
disaster that started off in with
Portugal but then reached uh Spanish
Galia can also reach other European
coasts this situation shows us that we
definitely need to boost controls of uh
transporting toxic uh waste uh AC around
Europe we ALS and and toxic products uh
around Europe we have to boost
monitoring and we have to be able to
quickly
react uh in line with the principle
pollut pay companies and businesses need
to Bear more responsibility for any lost
containers it must be more profitable to
actually guarantee the security than pay
the insurance policy we also need tools
that will help local communities to
fight for clean environment it's the
guarantee of our health and health of
animals we cannot let oceans to become a
free waste dump thank you thank you very
much the next speaker is Mrs Bilo
barandika
the plastic pellet spill that affects
the western coast of the Iberian
Peninsula and especially Galicia could
lead us to a discussion on the local
reaction given this accident but I think
uh there are those who spending more
time on who saw this first and who
reported it instead of focusing on how
to apply the lessons we learned after
the prestige spill this is what we're
trying uh in the Bas country
with a public private partnership called
ichas era bringing together the fishing
fleet authorities and scientific
institutes the debate is local and it
could spill over into the one here which
of course we have has to take place we
have to focus on prevention and avoiding
new spills and discharges uh we have to
make sure that the IMO says this is
materialist hazardous we have to look at
transport and monitoring and the
industry the Plastics industry has to
apply technology and Innovation to look
for Alternatives and we Face another
challenge we are already decided on the
phase out of single use Plastics let us
set deadlines so that in the future we
transport plastic pellets in a format
that if there is a spill it can be easy
to collect thank you thank you very much
Mr
Guerrero thank you president
commissioner
colleagues this tragedy which
unfortunately occurred in galsia and is
affecting the coast of Portugal too does
show us one positive point about the EU
now you see all kinds of accusations
flying back and forth from the far right
and so on but here we see that the EU
institutions have actually done a good
job we have legislation in the
parliament but also internationally to
ensure that the entire production and
distribution chain of these Goods which
should be considered has a materials is
efficient
and allowing for a response to such
emergencies the
European uh Maritime safety uh agency
would set up in the aftermath of The
Prestige disaster has now shown us how
the EU can respond
together there are a few uh YouTube
clips and uh Tik toks and uh
so on uh which explain this a lot
forward I'd be I'd be happy to take
question thank you the next speakers Mr
mat thank you very much president we're
worried about the plastic pellet spill
lost in Portugal and that is affecting
cabia the Bas country in Galicia of
course we're worried but the Nationalist
left is only interested in the regional
elections in Galia on the 18th of
February that is why the debate is
taking place they're worried about the
fact that uh there are problems but the
left is only worried or rather
interested in making sure that the
everyone sees the regional government
and giss in a bad light uh and yet we're
worried about other things that you are
not the nationalists and the left are
only interested in the 18th of February
were interested in finding solutions for
all the beaches affected and making sure
that this never happens again but the
left and the nationalists don't care
about the fact that their campaign
against the Juna will affect the Fishers
in Galicia it's all about the 18th of
February and
unfortunately there is a deadline to
your terrible campaign and that is the
18th of February but until then we will
continue along the same track despite
the Socialists and despite the
Nationalist we will work for the welfare
of the galicians and all Spaniards every
single Spaniard thank you as Mr Carlos
can you have the
floor we are
Point yes a point of order we needed
interpretation from French when Mr M
spoke but we didn't get that so we
didn't unfortunately hear what Mr M had
to
[Applause]
say I I didn't get Greek interpretation
either Mr Chim chair I will stay on
topic at light
on it seems invisible but it's actually
a disaster a disaster only becomes
visible once you take a C through the
sand because there are so many small
pellets there it might not seem
dangerous but as microplastic pollution
these pellets are a threat to Nature um
the environment but also the fishing
industry as well it's no good having
good intentions to avoid these sort of
accidents everybody concerned all the
stakeholders have to make sure that
these pellets aren't lost because we
need to stop this sort of local disaster
and to do that the local authorities
need to be prepared and it doesn't seem
to be the case here we also need to
wonder why there's so much waste coming
why do we need all this of plastic we
have to deal with our plastic addiction
and the way way that plastic is used for
bottles and bags we need to stop those
and we're going in the right direction
on that front but we need to make sure
that microplastic pollution doesn't
remain invisible in our ecosystems and
our environment thank
you thank you very much Mrs Rodriguez
Ramos thank you president six containers
from the ship toonel at 150 bags with 25
kilos of in each an environmental
tragedy but alas not an isolated
case between 52,000 and 180,000 pellets
are lost in the environment in the EU
annually for that reason commissioner it
is absolutely necessary for the pellet
regulation to include Maritime transport
of pellets has to be in the scope we
need a European law that will lay down
specific obligations for economic
operators and those in the transport
sector to avoid loss of pellets but also
commissioner we need a law with a clear
protocol as to how the 27 EU member
states should behave to avoid the kind
of events which unfortunately we've seen
in Spain recently since the 8th of
December we don't know what the Spanish
government has actually done to stop
pellets washing up on the shore with
regional governments asking questions
about whether these are toxic or not for
God's sake plastic plastic in the ocean
it's not good news so let's end these
political battles the gisan elections
will one day be over but the plastic
will still be there on the coast thank
you very much the next speaker is Mrs O
Sullivan this my friends is an oil spill
by another name the spilling of millions
of plastic pellets into the sea of
galsia is a crime it should be
considered as serious as the oil tanker
Prestige spill off the coast of G galaa
in 20 in 2002 or the many other hundreds
of environmental disasters we have
become familiar with in this plastic age
unlike the transport of materials like
crude oil which is classified as a
hazardous hazard to transport there is
still no such regulation for the
transport of crude
Plastics this must change the
petrochemical plastic industries cannot
be defended we should act like the
people of H skarin in my constituency in
Ireland South who when a large
multinational tried to build a plastic
pellet Factory in their beautiful St
Scenic town they said loud and clear we
will not support the plague of plastic
and I
[Applause]
agree thank you very much Mr Milan Monon
is the next
speaker thank you very much president
commissioner as I feared there's been a
lot of
exaggeration uh and lies I don't think
that this debate would be taking place
if we didn't have elections around the
corner and this is proof there's been a
dual Injustice in
Gala the government has been aware of
the accident they were aware on the 8th
of December but they only informed the
regional government on the 3rd of
January they didn't carry out their
duties and they didn't activate the
plans necessary commissioner
sinius the Galician Regional government
is not going to rest until all beaches
are clean it is rolling out and
deploying Resources by air and sea uh
Way Beyond its uh Powers uh there has
been a lot of
disinformation uh Li spill if you like a
tide of Lies uh from various people
saying that photos from Sri Lanka and
Texas were actually showing the
situation in Galicia but they weren't so
let us uh use common sense let us be
reasonable stop this um electoral these
electoral Maneuvers it's going to
tarnish the image of Galia and the
industry we're not going to allow this
thank
you the next speaker is Mrs Shel
Mo right now we're witnesses to a
environmental catastrophe on our
coasts the plastic pellets from ships
they contaminate our seas they wash onto
our beaches and they're being eaten by
birds and fishes alike because they look
like Plankton they then come into the
animals they won't decompose and when
small fish are eaten by bigger ones well
the plastic goes along so our nature
suffers we have to do everything we can
to clean this up we need plastic out of
our oceans that's our task right now but
in the long term we also need to make
sure that an environmental environmental
catastrophe like this cannot happen we
need political
Solutions in December six containers
fell off a
ship at the Spanish code so we need to
be the first in here in Europe to
suggest that we need better rooms we
have better rules we have to stop this
thank you very much Mrs
Aguilera
thank you
president I'd like to take this first
opportunity to express my gratitude to
Civil Society especially in galsia what
extraordinary efforts have gone into the
clear up and elimination of uh waste on
the coastline of Galicia we're seeing
Civil Society in galaa showing that it
is definitely up to the task which I'm
not sure that we have shown ourselves to
be in this
The Fishery sector is a professional one
let them get on with their jobs
commissioner I think you were quite
right to say that this new environmental
disaster should allow us to put in place
effective prevention measures in the EU
to avoid future spills and the damage
caused by microplastics let us learn the
lesson from this terrible situation but
we need
action the government of Galia is
showing itself to be highly negligent we
need to avoid the environmental impact
we can do the finger pointing later we
need to act now the pp in Spain the EP
in Europe and the far right who seem to
have already left should suddenly be so
concerned about this because there are
elections coming up if all the waste
that was generated in in Spain
uh is mounting up it would overshadow
this sort of pathetic attempt to point
the finger at Pedro Sanchez now
it's it just has no
credibility so we have come to the end
of the list of speakers and we can move
on to the catch the
procedure I have seven
requests given the seriousness of the
debate and how important this is I will
accept all seven requests Mr Herbst has
one
minute uh thank you Mr President um this
is a very important issue for all of us
in Europe uh and it truly is just a tip
of the iceberg so um let's just put the
election campaigning aside and my
question would be also to the
commissioner how did the Spanish
government inform you and how were
France for example as a neighboring
country informed by the Spanish
government this is a crucial European
question and uh I I recognize that uh
not many colleagues here talked about
for example the uh legislative package
on Maritime security and I also remember
that somebody who spoke one month ago
here in Parliament Mr Sanchez did not
talk about this issue at
all I mean Frankly Speaking did not talk
about European issues at all all so my
question would be uh how did the Spanish
government inform uh the European
government the next
speaker is Mrs
carves dear colleagues millions of
pellets on the beaches of galsia that is
an environmental disaster the regional
authorities can say they're not toxic
but we're talking about
nonbiodegradable materials on a huge
scale that will remain in marine
ecosystems for an indefinite period with
a longlasting effect on those ecosystems
and on the fisheries and seafood sectors
and those who depend on Coastal tourism
too so we need rapid action to minimize
environmental impact and the econom IC
impact too as we go into summer and we
need an EU response showing that we have
the necessary measures in place to
prevent a replay of this ever we need to
avoid vessels using flags of convenience
in order to circumvent security and
environmental uh rules which we have in
the EU because they're much laxer
elsewhere so we do need concrete action
commissioner thank you very much the
next speaker is Mr
so graas thank you very much president
I'd like to offer my support to the
Galan people once again they're
grappling with an ecological disaster
affecting their seas and beaches but
they're also dealing with the
incompetence of the gisan regional
government that reacted too late and
badly unfortunately where I come from in
Catalonia we've also grappled with
plastic pellet pollution
this is particularly serious and it
affects uh Pineda near taragona and the
prochemical industry there after having
dealt with all those in the value chain
and putting forward
um uh good practices and thanks to civil
society as well the Catalan government
has taken eight uh chemical companies to
court and the public prosecutor has
stepped in as well we have to be able to
find what lies behind this the root
causes and to ensure that there uh
there's
accountability we welcome European
legislation commissioner sovich but
there should be more tools available to
avoid these spills and therefore
pollution there cannot be impunity if
there are such
disasters thank you very much Mr Calis
is
next thank you very much president
debated about the the decision of Norway
to drill the deep sea in the Arctic and
we ask for a moratorium if that doesn't
happen and they drill do you know what
they will find they will find plastic
there's so much plastic ska are
calculated there is 100 billion tons
every year there is a great plastic
Garbage Patch plastic island in the
Pacific Ocean which is three times the
size of France and there are five of
these islands and we produce more and
more plastic so dear Commission Lich
when this mandate began we talked about
a blue deal and you've done a great job
you pushed forward the ocean agreement
in the biodiversity cop 15 in Montreal
kumin you reach an agreement on the
Beyond jurisdiction high seas
regulation I think it's time to be
serious about our zero pollution uh um
commitment on the green deal talk about
the next mandate and realize that we
must stop the plastic addiction PL
Plastics are fossile fuels and the
people of Galicia are suffering from
another oil SP like Grace said 20 years
later we must deal with that and realize
that transitioning away from fossil
fuels as we discussed in cop 28 includes
getting away from Plastics thank
[Applause]
you thank you very
much Mr
tabella micro
please
there are thousands of tons of plastic
pollution that are being tipped into the
sea which are threatening the uh
environment according to data
100,000 um mammals in the sea are
suffering as a result and are killed so
soon there's going to be more plastic
than fish in the sea but it's also a
question of Public Health because we're
looking at these microplastic pet
pollution and for our children and their
children they're being threatened The
Proposal from the commission to deal
with plastic P pollution is good
starting point but the European
Parliament I think needs to be more
ambitious it's more than high time to
fight this ecological and health
disaster and unfortunately this is
something that seems to be happening
again in the
game thank you very
much Mrs SAS
thank you president commissioner
colleagues we saw a tragic accident with
the prestige 20 years ago now we see
another environmental tragedy on the
same territory with very serious
consequences not only for local
communities it is not a regional problem
this is a European
issue and as Shadow reporter for the new
rules I would say we need much harsher
sanctions in order to ensure we have
stricter observance of the rules the
competent authorities should have an
environmental impact assessment of such
disasters and Implement preventive
measures in order to avoid future
environmental disasters allow me to
conclude by expressing my solidarity
with galissa and my sisters and brothers
in Galia and all those who are working
hard to mitigate the consequences of the
disaster thank you very
much Mr gal is the last speaker under
catdi thank you president ladies and
gentlemen 26 tons of plastic pellets
when they fall into the sea is it's
tragic it's an accident but above all it
it shows a lack of responsibility for
the companies are meant to assume uh
responsibility for the shipping
companies who are shipping these pellets
that there is a possibility of them
falling in the sea they have to cover
that and this is the huge problem
environmental pollution still is too
cheap there's an economic calculation by
firms involved that they are willing to
run that risk we need to stop that and
that's why it's so incred L important
that we have uh rules on plastic pellets
that are put in place and ensure
genuinely that on an international level
the oceans and the work done in these
regions be taken into
consideration obviously there's no point
if we just make sure that plastic
pellets within the uh internal waterways
of the EU aren't lost we need
International standards we are
responsible to the environmental
movement and to all of these people who
are now spending their their time to
sift through the sand to get the pallets
out again thank you very much that
brings us to the end of the catch the
procedure now Mr sinitus
commissioner thank you very much
honorable
Members First of all what's very clear
that today's debate shows the importance
of tackling pollution by plastic pellets
as well as the complexity of this issue
there are no easy solutions but we do
need bold and decisive action to protect
our oceans and to deliver on the Zero
pollution Target we are committed to
reducing plastic litter at Sea by 50%
and microplastic released into the
environment by 30% by 2030 some may be
inclined to look at these targets as
sort of nice figures but when pollution
strikes for real like on the Spanish
Coast we see that environmental concern
climb to the top of the political agenda
so the success will depend on our joint
coordinated efforts to support decisive
and Rapid actions and decisions at all
relevant levels regarding Maritime
transport dear colleagues I heared your
requests and we are ready to consider
its inclusion in EU law for instance to
forbid The Carriage of and B can work
together on ensuring good quality
packaging and safe storage on board
ships we are also calling on all parties
involved to act at International levels
we urge all member states to unite their
efforts at the international Maritime
Organization for a swift conclusion of
the deliberations on this topic thank
you thank you very much the debate is
closed so we can move on to the next
item on the agenda which is the mat
report implementation of the common
Fisheries policy and future
perspectives Mr mat the reporter has the
floor